attend the meetings write the show up
for the meetings you attend the meetings
you see what they're about see what the
deal is what is he trying to accomplish
maybe he has some really good saying
he's trying to accomplish God put
outward or we don't know yet maybe his
vision is that this only will only hold
these mandatory meetings until we get to
flow and gets everybody on board and
then he can go cool we don't have to do
this anymore you guys got it I don't
know what his vision is you know what's
he trying to make happen
let's give him that credit as the leader
to say hey you know you're calling this
meeting we're going to show up there
we're going to do our best to
participate and and get the most out of
the meeting find out what it's all about
so go to the meetings then now you got
your guys so you might be a little bit
worried about your guys right saying hey
why you make those a dentist's meeting
that dhamaal said we got to go to and on
that one what I would likely do is make
everyone attend a few and I would do it
say hey guys the boss having a meeting
know we're not going to get paid but
look we're gonna get word we're to find
out what's going on so I want everyone's
everyone's gotta be right so you don't
pass the buck you maintain the the
responsibility of what's happening you
own it and then maybe maybe after a
little while though you look at the boss
you say hey boss you know what these
meetings are good to go and get a lot
out of them but I'm not gonna make like
I don't want to make my guys go I want
to pass the word to them so is that all
right if I have them skip the meetings
but I'll be there and then I'll put out
the information and you know most likely
you'll get a hey that sounds good
especially if you've been attending the
meetings and you've been participating
you've been raising your hand and saying
taking notes and saying yeah we got that
boss we can make that happen if you've
been we oh is that kissing ass no no
it's building a relationship right now
there is a distinction right between
kissing ass and building relationship
and don't kiss ass because you're not
building a relationship when you kiss
ass as a matter of fact people are
turned off by it but you don't want to
be that guy hey boss what a wonderful
meeting I got so much out of it no no
but participate and get in the game
that's all I'm saying I'm not saying
kiss kiss kiss ass I'm going to get you
it's gonna it's gonna look bad I mean
are there some bosses that that feed off
of that yes there are and all you got to
be might have to play that game a little
bit you might have to play that game
Lu's not going to feel good that's why
we have to put our ego in check yes
and then yeah that's what I would do so
I think you made the right call
let's get and go to go to a bunch of
these meetings see what they're all
about
and maybe you know eventually you're
saying hey boss you know these are
uncompensated we could probably utilize
these hours better if we did some this
or we did that you know this is a good
good straightforward method I think you
made the right call and let us know how
it goes